[Musique]
attention la gauche
vous m'excuserez je dois retourner n'ont
rien faire on a déjà parlé de ça c'est
dur de respecter ta bulle quand tu
goûtes le beurre d'arachide
avez vous un peu les paresseux gâté
grassouillet voilà c'est dit c'est pas
comme si le magasin doit aller exploser
d'arachide
[Musique]
ton vrai un nouvel endroit encore mieux
que le magasin c'est aussi bon qu'une
carte postale c'est parfait voici un
parc qui génère sert aux profits mais
j'ai un plan pour tous ces arbres un
grand parc d'attractions ils vont
détruire le parc c'est un petit monsieur
avec une mini pelle et il est pas
dangereux
à la comprend la mini pelle c'était pour
le spectacle ce parc faut la peine qu'on
se bat pour lui je m'en charge
tout va bien mais je vous laisse le
suivre mes plans des villes fonctionne
pas où te suivre et main pour tout seul
où tu peux le faire toi de jouer
marc tout seul j'y arriverais pas vous
travaillez ensemble si on veut les
arrêtés jeudi par terre
qu'est ce que tu fais roule par terre je
sais pas comment je connais pas mes
classiques des trophées remontée grâce à
l'existence de ce jeu mais qu'une
enfance personnel tombale été attaqués
par des animaux des petits rongeurs via
le charger les gars est vraiment très
bon
[Musique]
les dates
cinquante revient sûrement normes de
sécurité
oh
[Musique]
désolé